>>> THERE'S GRING PRESSURE ON
E WHITE HOUSE TONIGHT TO BRING
WNBA STAR BRITTNEY GRINER HOME
FROM RUSSIA WHERE SHE'S BEEN
HELD IN DETENTION FOR MORE THAN
THREE MONTHS.
CNN'S BRIAN TODD ON THE STORY
FOR US, WHAT CAN YOU TELL US?
>> Reporter: TONIGHT, SOME OF
THE NBA'S TOP STARS IN THE
MIDDLE OF CHAMPIONSHIP SERIES
USIC THAT PLATFORM FOR CALM FOR
HER FREEDOM, AND A MAN WHO
HIMSELF WAS RECENTLY DETAINED BY
PUTIN'S REGIME.
>> YOU HAVE TO TELL THEM YOU
WANT THEM BROUGHT HOME AT ANY
COST, YOU DON'T CARE WHAT THAT
COST IS.
>> TREVOR REED, FORMER MARINE
HELD IN RUSSIA UNTIL A RECENT
SWAUPT, PUTTING PRESSURE ON THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TO GET
RELEASE OF TWO OTHER AMERICANS,
BRITTNEY GRINER.
DRIVING UP THE PRESSURE, HIGH
PROFILE FIGURES IN THE NBA AND
WNBA SHOWING SOLIDARITY FOR
GRINER AND TALKING ABOUT HER
CASE AT PRESS CONFERENCES.
>> WE ALL, YOU KNOW, TOGETHER,
SUPPORT TRYING TO BRING HER
BACK.
>> STARS LIKE LeBRON JAMES
JOINING THE PUSH FOR GRINER'S
RELEASE, WITH JAMES TWEETING OUR
VOICE AS ATHLETES IS STRONGER
TOGETHER.
FANS HOLDING SIGNS AT GAMES WITH
PHRASES LIKE "FREE BRITNEY" THE
PRESSURE CAMPAIGN, INCLUDES
WIFE, SHEREL, RECENTLY TELLING
ABC SHE WANTS TO SPEAK WITH
BIDEN.
>> IF THEY'RE HOLDING HER
BECAUSE THEY WANT YOU TO DO
SOMETHING THEN I WANT TO YOU DO
IT.
>> GRINER HAS BEEN JAILED IN
RUSSIA SINCE MID FEBRUARY,
SAYING THEY FOUND CANNABIS OIL
IN HER LUGGAGE AT A MOSCOW
AIRPORT.
HAVING MORE A GREENLIGHT TO
SPEAK OUT NOW SINCE THE
GOVERNMENT CLASSIFIED HER AS
"WRONGFULLY DETAINED" MEANWHILE,
A NEW WINDOW TONIGHT FROM TREVOR
REED INTO THE CONDITIONS GRINER
AND WHEELAN COULD BE FACING .
>> IT'S REALLY MEDIEVAL THE FOOD
AS WELL, ALWAYS ROTTEN, I LOST
90 POUNDS THERE FROM
MALNUTRITION.
>> TELLING CNN GRINER HAS BEEN
ABLE TO RECEIVE LETTERS WHILE IN
DETENTION FROM FAMILIES AND
FRIENDS.
>> ARE THE RUSSIANS READING
THEM?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THERE'S NOTHING PRIVATE IN A
RUSSIAN PRISON.
ANYTHING COMING TO HER WILL HAVE
BEEN READ PRESUMABLY BY NUMEROUS
PEOPLE.
>> Reporter: REED AND OTHERS
ALSO WORRY THAT WIDESPREAD
HOMOPHOBIA IN RUSSIA COULD BE
WORKING AGAINST GRINER.
>> SHE IS OPENLY GUY IN A
COUNTRY THAT IS, TORTURES AND
KILLS MEMBERS OF THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY.
IT'S A TERRIBLE SITUATION.
CONDITIONS ARE NOT GOOD.
AND THERE'S ABUSE, BOTH FOR
WOMEN AND MEN.
THIS IS THE LAST PLACE ON EARTH
YOU WANT TO BE.
>> Reporter: THE STATE
DEPARTMENT SAYS THAT GRINER